you did the cover story on pimco this
morning you spoke to bill's wife what
have you learned
well it was really obvious to me when he
and i spoke a few months ago that he was
very deeply unhappy and he had been
incredibly successful as an investor but
that success brought all sorts of new
management problems his firm got so big
and unwieldy that he needed a lot of
help to run it and as by his own
admission he's an introvert he's sort of
a dork he likes to hide behind his
screens and look at bond prices he is
not the guy who likes to go around sort
of making sure everyone's happy doing
hiring decisions hr all that stuff and
let's not forget about likes to do yoga
doesn't like to travel much doesn't like
to surround himself with a lot of people
gets a little bit claustrophobic he's a
man of routine he eats special k with
blueberries every single morning he has
a cat yeah tom stephanie raised an
excellent question how much money
is going to follow bill gross to janice
whether it's new money or whether it's
pimco money because you were going to be
here i did some math
i know that that's scary
but if you think about it this way up
until yesterday janus equity shares of
janus were trading at about 1.175
percent of genesis assets under
management right that's the way asset
management companies trade as a
percentage of assets under management
they have a new market cap today thanks
to the bill gross news the stock is up
some 35 percent
if you do a little bit of math you come
to the conclusion that the market is
implying using that same multiple janus
is going to have 235 billion dollars of
assets under management makes bill gross
a 60 billion dollar market that's very
much a legitimate uh mathematical
calculation i think the the idea here is
he's a marquee name john bogle said that
this morning marty fritz and margie
patel and and others as marty said this
is a true rock star 70 a couple tough
years but yes he can bring in new money
the moving money is a fascinating
question uh a number of the interviews
we had made clear retail could move the
little investors he's the bond king the
guru the expert why leave and go to
janus why not leave and start his own
fund and go hedge fund style and collect
the 2 and 20.
i think first of all in the bond market
that's a much tougher proposition than
in the equity market but so much of this
is sheila alludes to why there's a ton
of credit hedge funds there's a ton of
macro funds that's not what he does bill
bill gross works the full faith and
credit market it's a different
racket than the hedge funds i go to
where sheila is is this is a lifestyle
move he wants a much smaller hold on i
disagree i think that he's the biggest
player in the credit markets he without
a doubt could start a credit headshot i
think there and i i want to chime in
here with a couple of
thoughts on this um okay first off why
janice right well it is a chief rival to
pimco but also there's a relationship
between dick weil and bill gross that
goes back many years ago while was the
pimco ceo for several years
and so sources are telling me that in
many ways this is a classic bill gross
move i mean this guy is not interested
in leaving and uh and sort of quietly
going away he had something to prove he
was being pressured to leave pimpko his
behavior was getting worse but there is
there is a good question as to why janus
janice while certainly a rival to pimco
has been something of a pathetic rival
to pimko in his mind oh it's been a very
pimple manages almost two billion no no
but hang on tom pimco manages
almost two trillion dollars in assets
janus which is historically a growth
equity business manages 177 billion
we're talking about ten percent i would
go back to the assets sheila i would go
back to july of this year where janice
announced they're taking on myron shoals
the nobel laureate that's people that
bill gross
likes to be around likes to hang out
with it's not a small idea that i was
literally one day at pimco and michael
spence walked through the hallway well
pimco is structured like an intellectual
sort of hot house where they really
value the exchange of ideas and that is
something that bill gross loves now
of course there has been some turmoil
there in recent months and there are
folks there who have reported to
bloomberg and other outlets that he
wasn't necessarily dealing with
contradictory points of view very well
and all this turmoil made it into the
press that's a very nice way yes uh
there were rangers
doug cass this morning wrote a scathing
note
about bill gross at 70. that you know
you know everyone knows i'm i'm quite
close with bill the fact is he's 70 he's
down the road on a career and all
reports are it's been an immense
challenge to run pimco for the young
marquis
responsibility that was left by the way
to muhammad al-ararian to run the
company and then look what happened they
butted heads and el aryan left and and
there isn't any indication that he's
coming back what about valerian's job
hold on just just so people understand
valerian's job there and what was bill's
job there so bill was the one who and
sheila you know this i mean he's the one
who he wanted to run the funds he wanted
to manage he was the big thought leader
at pimco uh not that mohamed ellerian
was not himself but he was really out
there in the press he was sort of like
an ambassador for pimco but he also ran
the operations at the company he phil
was the investor right and bill as we
all bill gross is not an operator he is
not a ceo we have a piece of breaking
news to inject into this conversation
our sources that is to say bloomberg
sources are telling us that dan iverson
one of the deputy chief investment
officers appointed in the wake of that
fracas that forced or that prompted
elarian to leave is likely to succeed
bill gross as the chief investment
officer and that isn't going to surprise
too many people iverson certainly had to
be among the front runners mark keisel
also named as a potential successor as
well as scott mather who has been
running the global business but uh the
nod appearance appears to be going to
dan iverson
this morning do you know dan
i met with him when i worked on my piece
for business week he's very impressive
very well regarded and although they did
promote a number of people around that
time into the sort of chief investment
officer role and they were clearly
taking steps to plan for the moment when
bill perhaps stepped away for whatever
reason dan's name was always at the
forefront he's a very very respected he
has a huge job
does he not we talked about the
possibility that retail money will exit
pimco's total return fund that gross
managed right away and the retail
investors can do that institutions on
the other hand and so much of pimco's
money is institutional money
and not reflected necessarily in the
total return fund is subject to review
right every single institutional manager
now has to initiate an asset allocation
and it's going to be a revie
of time whether to keep the money at
pimco and ivanson presumably is going to
be the man at the front lines trying to
keep the money from walking out i would
suggest that we've seen this many times
before not only ugly times at putnam
when it blew up 8 10. well more than
that 12 15 years ago but i go to
american funds capital guardian trust in
los angeles when mr lovelace moved on
there's a hierarchy shift and you manage
this iverson is a kind of person that's
what he gets paid for is to herd the
cats not that that would ever happen in
television but heard the cats and you
know get everybody in order while still
hiring intellectual firepower that's
what muhammad did yes muhammad got the
horses that's right well they muhammad
was involved in investing but basically
he would split his day he would come in
ungodly early
do his sort of market analysis write
whatever op-eds he had to write and he
would sit on the trading floor until
around 9 00 a.m right next to bill and
then at nine he would move to the
executive suite and do his management
duty and that was the part that bill
really did not like this is the second
enormous job opportunity in two days
that's come up where muhammad al-ararian
was a potential candidate right running
the harvard management company which he
once did and was and it was thought
perhaps he might return
and now pimco which he obviously once
ran as chief executive officer or
co-chief executive officer and and a way
to undersell eric maybe he doesn't want
to do either of those because he loves
being a blues
are you kidding me by all indications uh
he is happy with what he's doing right
now he spends half of his time at
allianz not on pimko uh pimko stuff but
he's working on other things at allianz
and he's happy to be working and and
doing the things that he was saying that
said he wanted to do what you spend time
with his family very quietly yesterday
the telegraph in london had the article
on his 10 year old daughter where
muhammad finally discussed right now
yeah discuss the the idea that this was
about his family and the cri you know we
all know that crushing ours i mean you
look at stephanie rule's 35-hour work
week it's almost as bad as mohammed's
please i'm working 35 hours a
interesting about week he wrote this
article for worth magazine this is what
we're talking about he wrote this
article for worth magazine speaking
about his work-life balance and spending
time with his daughter three months ago
and now in europe for some reason of the
telegraph and the guardians
they suddenly
and he's now trending in europe right
now as this sort of beacon of work-life
balance she i have a question with your
recent reporting that's more of a
work-life balance exactly they're just
working too hard over there they are is
there acclaimed morning meetings still
the same i have trouble i've had the
privilege of being in it
bill not there muhammad not there that's
a different morning meeting well there
were some complaints internally that if
bill or muhammad or both of them or one
of them were there that they would it
would have this sort of chilling effect
because everyone else would feel a
little intimidated about speaking their
mind and possibly offending one or the
other of them
and this is something bill spoke to me
about he said that he felt like there
were two pillars and they were a little
too authoritative perhaps and that the
power balance wasn't fostering the kind
of intellectual
mix yeah marty fritzen today was
acclaimed a fixed income manager said
this is a real distinction and that bill
gross had a huge belief
and call on macroeconomics which folded
over tick by tick to the sweat of trying
to make alpha i mean
he brought the economics world right
into finance and that always is
contentious always